être les essayer à oublier ce
mometututututututututututututut.
c c c c c c c c c c c c c c c :
l'installation de croix
à la més s s s s victimes.
Ici, on cherche le réconfort,
un câlin de consolation...
Et quelques caresses aussi
pour se changer les idées,
le temps d'un instantououououour
à l'horreur pourtant
inoubliable.
Et puis, surtou
et on ose pleurer ses morts.
Ce rituel réconfortant, F F F e
depuis 10 ans un peu partout
aux États-Unis, en fait depuis
la tuerie à l'é
Des croix, il y en a aussi
devant l'école, th
du carnage de mardi.
Pour Dora Mendoza, grand-mère
de la petite Alalalalalalalalal,
la peine est immense
et inconso
qui ont survécu à la tuerie
qu'il faut réconforter.
Le pasteur Michael Johnson
y participe en apportant
cadeaux, mais surtout en donnant
du temps pour les écouter,
les comprendre et les aider
à vivre avec ces terribles
Alors, quelle solution
éviter une autre tragédie?
Et le contrôàààààààà feu
dans tout ça? Joe Morales,
ancien élève de l'école,
d'une certaine partie
de la cacacacacacacacacaine,
qui pense que la sécurité
dans les écoles fait défaut.
c'est une vache sacrée
s s s s s s s s s toucher.
répandue.
Entre lsssssssss
réponse et le douloureux deuil,
les Texans souffrent en silence.
cette souffrance fera partie
de
Ici Frédéric Arnould,
Radio-Canada, Uvalde, au Texa